sorry I cost this way I did I would love
to be in the middle of a conversation
and I was out the party the other day
and this guy comes up to me
hey guys i'm ryan right Milana today
we're gonna check out from the richest
10 of the sexiest criminals ever I'm
hoping these are some hot-ass females I
agree because you know what nothing
nothing sounds hotter than a woman who
is bad you know yeah probably down for
some crazy-ass [ __ ] I need a list that
tell me this the 10 sexiest criminals
Jeremy means starting us off is possibly
the poster child for sexiest criminals
everywhere arrested in June 2014 Jeremy
Meeks his mug shot turned heads and
quickly went viral arrested during a
gang sweep in Stockton California police
described Meeks as one of the most
violent criminals in the area who will
spend the next two years behind bars
with his chiseled jaw captivating blue
eyes
most people quickly overlook this fact
and simply know him as one of the
sexiest criminals ever there were even
rumors that various modeling agencies
were fighting it out to see who would be
the ones to dress this dangerous bank
robber
Megan McCullough mmm in July 2010 this
mother of four was arrested on a DUI in
Tampa Florida still drunk tired and
having spent most of the night crying
over her arrest
Megan McCullough had no idea that three
years later her mugshot would attract so
much attention and marriage proposals
now going by the name of Megan Simmons
the famous picture was quickly turned
into a meme as men everywhere became
infatuated with her not put off by all
the attention the woman known as the
attractive criminal has put those dark
days behind her even if her mugshot
continues to generate quite a few miles
with a crime
apparently a pretty hot criminal looking
at the mug shot it's hard to know that
Angela Coates had been arrested for
disorderly conduct
instead with her long hair sharp eyes
and full lips this Miami native looks
like she's on a photo shoot not about to
be put behind bars
this former jet magazine beauty of the
week so captivated anyone who saw a
picture of her that offers her bail came
flying in long after she'd been released
from jail
armie hammer know this sure that one
marijuana may not seem like a major
crime to you but it gives us an excuse
to include this next person in our ranks
of sexy criminals our mind hammer is a
Hollywood star who had appeared in such
films as the social network Jay Edgar
I'm the Lone Ranger in addition to
appearing on the big screen
he's also appeared behind bars thanks to
an arrest a few years ago cameras picked
out near the Mexican border while in
possession of a small amount of
marijuana his mugshot looks like
something out of a j.crew catalog which
qualifies him for our sexy criminal
status yeah
Lelaina Tucker in 2008 Lorena tavira was
named Miss El Paso Texas just a few
years later this pageant beauty was
arrested for shoplifting a $69 shirt
while the crime may have been stupid
most people quickly forget it thanks to
a rather sexy mugshot taken when Tamara
was being booked in the El Paso jail a
quick look through her portfolio and
we're pretty sure most guys would gladly
give this University of Texas student
the shirt off their back free of trouble
Shawn Cory in late 2014 the rest of
California Shawn Cory had everyone
labeling him as a direct competition to
Jason me sexiest criminal Cory's arrest
stems from a Halloween incident where he
assaulted an individual at a party after
apparently shouting I hate Fox News he
repeatedly struck a partygoer with a
tennis racket who was dressed up as a
news reporter like Meeks Cory posted a
rather sexy mug shot but also seems
destined to continue spending
considerable time behind bars
Lindsay Evans
remember that attractive blonde and
Robin Thicke's video for the popular
song blurred lines a couple years ago it
turns out she definitely qualifies as
one sexy criminal now known as L Evans
the model actress and Playboy Playmate
was arrested in 2008 just months after
she finishes third runner-up in the Miss
Teen USA pageant after a dinner I was
friends Evans allegedly thought it was a
good idea to dine in - unfortunately she
left her purse behind which contains
some marijuana
stripped of her crown this sexy criminal
Omaha ended up not hurting her career
one bit hairy Pierpont yeah even in the
era of prohibition there were sexy
criminals as hairy Pierpont demonstrates
Pierpont is best known as being a friend
and accomplice to the infamous John
Dylan no words cape on stand out was a
string of violent crimes in the 1920s
and 1930s which left a trail of murder
and bank robberies across the United
States in 1934 his luck ran out and the
former gangster was badly hurt in a
jailbreak
executed soon after Pierpont is almost
remembered as much for being an
attractive gangster as he is for his
string of crimes
Floyd Mayweather American concert Floyd
Mayweather is considered one of the
greatest fighters ever to live most of
us are familiar with his exploits in the
ring with this good-looking boxer has a
criminal past between 2002 and 2011
Mayweather had a string of run-ins with
the law related to charges of battery
and domestic violence in addition to his
rather fit physique everyone sees in the
ring
the boxing legends mugshots only further
confirmed that Floyd Mayweather is
definitely one sexy criminal Stephanie
bear doing 22 year old Stephanie Bowdoin
has been labeled the new sexiest
criminal on earth the Canadian nursing
students first came into headlines when
she was arrested on 114 counts related a
home invasion theft and the illegal
owning and storing of nine firearms
before her luck ran out this present-day
woman had struck 42 homes she gained
further no pictures of her in a bikini
were posted by a local paper the
combination of crime and sexy photos
have caught the attention of many people
all around the world as one tweet so
appropriately put it
Bowdoin will steal your heart then your
stuff thanks for watching this video
here's a couple other videos that we
think you might like and don't forget to
click Subscribe thanks those crimes were
like I mean except for like the
gangsters yeah I know
crazy crazy we shouldn't yeah I know
that was pretty insane actually I like I
like Lindsay Evans I'm a blonde guy okay
I like blondes oh yeah yeah love to see
you make out with a blonde from the
strake eye perspective that would be
cool to watch I think you like the
opposite no I like good-looking okay I
mean so I like the opposite oh she's
diamond - she died and - with some
marijuana tour perfect okay that's just
it's a dumb blonde
you don't dine and dash and leave your
purse and then the marijuana charges I
know like armie hammer got charged with
it I'm like come on people still get
arrested for that [ __ ] like really it's
not a big deal anymore
everyone does it besides the law huh
I definitely not do it I definitely
didn't do it before filming this video I
definitely didn't do it before filming
several videos the first guy Jeremy
Meeks I would think that was a male
model for the first time like if I was
like all this poor male model has such a
bright future ahead of him was actually
a gangster look at him when he gets out
as he already yeah he should just become
a rapper
yeah be a rapper or something you were
set if you're black and go to jail best
thing to do become a rapper I would you
earn all your respect back right away
mmm
cuz you're a badass and this guy he's
got the looks I feel like he's looking
at me right now like he's really
connected to the camera
my heart's beating did you just follow
him up I think he's in love
Angela Coates yes well okay not my
favorite face but that body let's go to
that bomb I think her her mug shot
though like in her other picture she's
okay her mug shot hot
yeah but she's kind of like [ __ ] legs
and ass and just boobs and like yeah
she's not like like oh she's just so
skinny it's repulsive you know yeah she
is a really great vibe she's got a great
body with huge knockers oh my god and
she's got hips you know like she's not a
pretty face but in the mug shot that
looked really yeah oh she looks really
good in her mug shot you know like I
would if I was in prison it it wouldn't
matter because they separate the men and
woman so never mind Lorena to Vera
probably this list is none of these
crimes are really that member no
criminal oh man how like such a hard
word to label someone criminal is like
something so small but yeah I know she
is like [ __ ] hot though I mean I
think she was the least heart of
everyone no I mean but think about it
she bought a $69 shirt she's trying to
say something you're right she wants
someone who likes sixty-nining case you
guys I know that is if you're too young
that's where like I'll be eating out a
girl and then she'll be blowing me up
this ain't like should be laid on top of
me or it's like I'm on top that's kind
of harder because then you're just got
like my body weight and then I'm like
County you know I guess I was good
no but Lorena tavera if you're watching
this we should think about each other
sometimes you just won I hope she
doesn't why I mean look at this photo of
her yeah that's nice that's a really
nice photo I I could touch myself to
that Wow I want to touch myself to that
I want you to leave so I can touch
myself today now the guy that ran lost
us a lot like the first criminal he does
feel like they said he was compared and
I totally see it cuz they look alike
except he has dreadlocks if you took off
the drives oh you could probably do with
some modeling yeah yeah I mean the
dreads he's kinda got that like predator
thing going on you know he can't he
looks it makes him look creepy and
questionable yeah it's not like oh
you're one of those cool laid-back kind
of guys with dreadlocks you smoke a lot
of weed and work at a marijuana
dispensary now he looks like he'd [ __ ]
up person up but they do have oh it's
his green eyes and those other guys blue
eyes yeah let's have a similar stare
divorce yeah and their nose he's got a
better face though the guy the first guy
he's no more than job he has more of a
jaw the cheekbones he's more aligned you
know he's got like he's got like a
celebrity head he is hot and he is
really good-looking I could touch myself
to him to him and having sex with okay
yeah Floyd Mayweather I didn't you know
it's funny how when someone is famous
you can sometimes forget about the
horrible things they've done yeah except
when it comes to Mel Gibson we all
remember that I remember like hearing
about Sean Penn like tying down Madonna
and beating her and like he'd won like
an Oscar ever since that happened and
Floyd Mayweather four charges of
domestic violence and [ __ ] and he's like
a lethal fighter so that's like
terrifying to know that he'd be taking
out his anger like that on people and
like your family home and stuff like
that nice you have to be careful with
like fighters yeah yeah you don't know
like he's like a deadly fighter that
makes me lose a lot of respect for him
but then I feel like if he happens to
come across this video and he hears me
say that I feel like he's gonna find me
and beat me to death
z like cuz it's a weapon at that point
that's why I like wait ma or what is it
what's up I don't know your weapon after
you like our professional fighter yeah
you're using a weapon on its own I was
happy I got my black belt in Taekwondo
when I was 11 years old so I was weapon
I was a lethal weapon jr. at that time I
am NOT a weapon no you're more like a
shield like you know so much shooting
we'd use you as the block yeah as the
block yeah yeah I don't even think I'm
big enough for that no that's the thing
you were you're not a good shield I'm
just like whatever you're not swimming
yeah you're not even like a worthy
shield like not a metal shield but more
like a plastic one yeah like you got
like a wooden one that like some 12 year
old kid built for you who's the son of a
welder hate to break it to you but I'm
more like serve no purpose yeah Wow it's
true I could be like the bullet I can
beat no you know what I could be the
horse deaf people ride away on no yeah
sure but you don't like like wait you
have the weapon you have the person
shooting no happen then you have the
horse like [ __ ] are you talking what war
do you think we'd fight it now anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you check out a la
Nicole's channel if you like fun and
then you'll like Alana cuz I want a coal
with her laughter makes you feel whole
[Music]
yeah I like filling holes too you know
what I mean and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter I have mine
in periscope and on Alana's channel we
just did a prank video where we call
some places and make up some [ __ ]
reactions okay and you have fast and
furious seven the seventh one
okay and you have Passion of the Christ
- the Messiah Strikes Back